chill how are you today good damn what's
up uh what'd you think of the three guys
who got in yesterday I'm so excited
especially for Jeff I play with Jeff his
rookie year in 1991 and I'll always
remember there are moments I'll remember
about players and the one I remember
about him was him hitting an upper deck
home run in the old pirate Stadium the
only hit 16 home runs his rookie year
but he had you know 50 home run power
and to watch him blossom mature and it
just interviewing one of the nicest and
most enjoyable teammates ever had was
there was a lot of fun I'm really happy
for him I'm I'm disappointed it took
this long for Tim Raines I think he I
would argue he's the second best leadoff
hitter in the history of the game in my
opinion should have been a long time ago
and then punch no you know what best
best catch our defensive catcher I've
ever seen so I'm happy for him who would
be the last guy you'd want to face out
of those three oh I didn't look at it
like that like I want those are the guys
I wanted to face Tim Raines was I was
always worried about the D on-base guys
you know Timmy hit the top of that
lineup but he understood what his role
was and I never liked that I never I
always liked guys who tried to be
players they weren't and none of those
guys did so Bonds and Clemens vote
totals went up why do you think they're
getting in oh because people are moving
on you know it's the the cause I think
for the original vote totals is
something they don't really care about
anymore and and yeah I think you're
gonna see them get in the next one or
two years should we care about that I
don't know let's say that's your
prerogative
you know I wouldn't vote for him but I'm
not you know I'm not the purveyor of the
owner the whole thing I don't think Oh
being caught cheating and I know blah
blah blah they never got caught that we
know for what we know I mean we just not
knowing the world that I lived in for 22
years I don't doubt it for a second so I
it sucks for me from the perspective of
Roger Clemens his influence of my career
was astronomical and
and I wasn't as mad as I was just really
disappointed so anyway but I also look
at this that we may look at the hitters
with suspicion or put asterisk by their
totals those in the steroid era but we
don't really bump up the pitcher who had
to face these I still maintain Pedro
Martinez what he did when he did it how
he did it in that ballpark facing
American League hitters including the D
H it's almost as if Pedro and I know
he's already a Hall of Famer but it's
he's underrated I think so let's be very
clear about something
1991 to 2001 was the greatest three-year
run in the history of the game by a long
long long margin when you compare
Koufax's historic run and it was
historic amazing when you look at any
other any other run in the era that what
today happened his stats were so far
outside the norm that there's nothing
there was nothing ever like that ever
before and they'll never ever be
anything like that again and I you know
I I even though I'm not a Josh earnest
fan it's something I think you and I can
agree on yes Curt Schilling joining us
three-time World Series champ your vote
total dipped again why mine because I'm
not I'm not quiet I think if I if I
didn't talk I might have gotten in this
time but you know me excuse me you know
that's not who I am and you also know I
think I I believe it's politics in one
sense but I also think the retweeting of
the t-shirt gave them and out so to
speak
you've known me how long what twenty
years maybe longer I don't believe I had
a lynching history in my past prior to
meeting you I don't believe I actually
glints anybody while I was in the big
leagues and I'm pretty sure I've never
written a paper or advocated for the
lynching of human beings i retweeted a
picture of a t-shirt that I thought was
humorous because I believe absolutely
believed in my heart of hearts that the
mainstream media has killed itself and
and as we know it it's the nature meet
as we know it is dead they just don't
know it yet but if I gave you a
redo a mulligan would you have retweeted
the t-shirt you know let me tell you why
I would not I would not because you know
how sick and tired I am of trying to
explain to people what I was doing and
unfortunately and I'm not blaming
everybody else a lot of times I'm on the
hook unfortunately I have to do that a
lot of times because of the things that
I do and see because in a hundred and
forty characters on Twitter
listen I can't I can't say no to my I
can't I can't do anything in life in 140
characters it's not too many possible
for me and it's not generally the best
format to communicate the tone and humor
and sarcasm doesn't generally translate
into Twitter as well as it does in real
life and you know I know that I
acknowledge that I I thought it was
funny I didn't think it was in any way
harmful certainly anybody knows me knows
I I'm I would never I I don't like to
have see people get hurt I thought it
was a sarcastic but you know what these
are the same people who were laughing at
the kill cops kill pigs t-shirts or they
were maybe not laughing but they sure as
hell we're talking about him you know
and and so or hands up don't shoot they
wore all those they were proud of those
but they never came out and said
anything when that was proven to be a
complete fabricated lie so I don't do
you think that you would be phony if you
don't respond because if I said if you
calm down you can get into the Hall of
Fame are you do you think you're then
are you capable of doing that
I don't know Dan and I guess there's a
lot of things I should here's the thing
you know what gets me I'm on Twitter and
a lot of people will troll me on Twitter
and I'll fire back with it with it you
know a lot of times I'll get it
somebody will say you know the blogging
you blowing your sock was fake and I'll
tweet back yeah but this is real and
it'll be a picture of the ring I like
embarrassing people on Twitter just like
I like embarrassing people in the stand
when I was playing the game you know
they'd yell over stuff and I'd say oh
hey listen I got my wallet here once you
hand me your paycheck I'll cash it for
you or something stupid just to make I'd
love to watch bullies or people that try
to demean people get get
get it handed to him and I was always
pretty good at it because I was always
on the other side of it they playing and
talking as much as I did I open myself
up to a lot of chryses and being built
the way I'm built and I always tell
people this isn't a body this is kind of
a cruel family joke that I got but I
game we play you bet in clubhouses
that's what we do but are you willing to
sacrifice the Hall of Fame listen if
that sacrifice is the Hall of Fame I
don't want to be in any way the Hall of
Fame if the writers in the halls that
vote for the Hall of Fame are going to
invoke quote unquote the character
clause and they're gonna randomly invoke
it then you know what so be it it wasn't
meant to be because if you want to
invoke the character clause in your ass
better put Dale Murphy and they're all
fames yesterday because he was one of
the finest human beings I've ever known
Annie was a Hall of Famer if you want to
book the character clause and vote for
Barry Bonds or Roger Clemens kiss my
butt and if you vote for Barry Bonds or
Roger Clemens and you don't vote for
Manny Ramirez
you're an idiot so you know if that's
ends up costing me votes okay so I I'm
not sure the character clause though
Kurt I thought the character clause had
to do with when you played I I don't
know yeah that's what I don't understand
that bonds and Clemens and their
character and what it did to the game
you didn't do anything that harmed the
game you're saying comments now that
have nothing to do with your baseball
career it's you as a person how does
that how is that attached to your
baseball career in baseball character
that's well I'm here to tell you that
the things that matter in my life
I think say far more about me then they
do then then the media does I won the
Roberto Clemente award the one award I
wanted to win during my baseball career
the Branch Rickey where all of the
awards I won for the OP the field stuff
I did were much more important to me
than anything else because they told
people more about who I was and what I
did and at the end of the day I wanted
to win an award that you didn't have to
pitch for because I wanted to make a
difference in people's lives and it's
the time and place is a player when I
could and I feel like we tried to do
that we could have done more absolutely
who couldn't but that's the way the
world works in like it's why I still and
I told you this I think you might have
been the first person I ever told this I
have never lost and we'll never lose one
second of sleep over this because I've
met and you know a couple weeks ago I
said something that I want to I don't
want to retract but I want to clarify
and I was talking about the fact some of
the worst scumbags I've ever met are
writers that's clearly the minority it
there are there are so many good people
even you as a liberal you're you're kind
of a good guy I mean but I never I
played with some really really bad
people and I watched bill Conlan get
inducted into get the Ford C Frick award
who was a pedophile
I watched people who I know we're really
really bad people be a be lauded as
being good people nothing but that's
everywhere and that's everything but for
though for me that can be concerned
about those people passing judgment on
my character now I'm not gonna worry
about that I can't control that and and
and it's a process I have no control
over it's a process humans are involved
in so there's going to be bias you
expect there to be biasing writers have
made no qualms about it listen bill
Conlan told me to my face and here's the
other thing dad I called them out for it
when people did stupid stuff I called
these when there was embarrassed people
on my team or they would try to write
something about me that wasn't true I
would call them out in the clubhouse and
embarrass them the way they embarrassed
me I didn't have a problem and that's I
think that's why a lot of them didn't
like me but but Bill Condon once told me
he did not vote for Nolan Ryan because
if say if Don Sutton didn't get in
unanimously the Nolan Ryan didn't
deserve to be m'gosh and he's not the
only one would you be for many would you
vote for Manny Ramirez I would not vote
for anybody that cheated so no but I did
this is what I'm trying to figure out
Kurt as we move forward because we're
moving forward and you're gonna have
guys who are known steroid users get it
can I can I have a line of demarcation a
mason-dixon line that says a before and
after testing and if you tested positive
or anybody who test positive from now on
you're automatically not eligible for
the Baseball Hall of Fame like I know I
know and your demarkation is or whatever
you want it to be again
I can't remember was it George King that
Hank you the writer in New York vote for
Pedro for the MVP
and he said I don't vote for pictures
well you noted for Mariano Vera any
bidding so again
your personal line of demarcation is
whatever you want it to be and that's
fine there are no solid guidelines to
this so there's going to be biasing you
and you know think about the fact that
Trevor Hoffman missed by five votes
yesterday and you look at some of the
people that got one vote it's
embarrassing that is if they use and
that's my dogs you stop shut up
sounded like a liberal there don't worry
about it just let that be let me do I
keep saying tonight this has been a
great teaching moment for my kids in the
sense that they know me they know who I
am and what I'm all about
and so when someone calls me a racist
and my youngest son goes I don't
understand how someone can do that how
come I mean what would you what have you
said and I said listen I'm gonna tell I
tell them what my dad told me when you
leave the house at 18 the word fair goes
out the window
it doesn't the doulton but don't be
cynical but the world is not looking to
be fair to you and so there are things
that are said about me here's the thing
then you've known me for 20 years do you
think I in any way shape or form I'm a
racist I I don't know you well enough
off the field but I there's nothing that
led me to believe that you are but I
don't I don't know that 22 years in the
game if I was a racist if I was John
Rocker do you not think as much as I
talk that somebody somewhere would have
heard me say something racist probably
but my point is the I think you're a
Hall of Fame pitcher I don't think it's
fair that they have these comments even
though I don't agree with most of your
comments it still wouldn't it doesn't
affect me and what I saw in a big game
whether it was with Philadelphia or
Arizona with Boston you're you're on the
short list of guys I would hand the ball
to and I don't think it's fair that your
character now is attached to your
baseball character your baseball career
so we can leave it at that and I don't
know what you know well I'll talk to you
next year Thank You Kurt
yeah buddy right and it's Curt Schilling
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]